students in the clark county school
district are back in class today after
spring break a break after what has been
so far a very violent semester ccsd's
superintendent acknowledged the issue in
an email saying violence won't be
tolerated still as mary jane belly is a
report some staff and parents are
concerned about the return she joins us
live at rex bell elementary near rancho
and sahara with more mary jane
heather good afternoon and today is the
first day back from spring break for
clark county school district students
but parents and even teachers are still
worried about the violence on school
campuses
since the beginning of the
2021-2022 school year ccsd has had over
5 thousand incidents of violence
reported on school campuses
superintendent dr jesus jarrah sent an
email to parents monday stating violence
will not be tolerated at schools he also
asked parents to show support for their
children parents i spoke with have a
mixed reaction on the issue i just worry
about my kid you know like all the kids
you know only my kid
and
i just hope the violence stopped i think
with the superintendent's message
addressing the school violence that it
will get better yeah and i hope so too
my daughter was just hit in the head two
months ago by another kid
from another school the principal here
he's a good principal but the other
school they're not with it do you think
the superintendent's message you know
about trying to take responsibility and
with violence not being tolerated that
there will be change no
i don't
dr jara also states that this isn't just
a school district issue but also a
statewide problem he says what happens
in our schools also mirrors what is
happening in our community
now a rally hosted by the education
support employees association will be
held at el dorado high that is all set
for 3 p.m today it's all to raise
awareness about this issue reporting
live near sahara and rancho mary jane
balliesa live local now